[Music]
before you drive past Gran Turismo check
out a forgotten gym of a racing movie
that's so fast-paced and insane you'll
swear you're watching the original
cartoon
[Music]
the show is hardcore
stop crying it won't do any good and
anyway you have a lot of work to do
starting right now
Speed Racer
after the Matrix C the wachowskis could
do anything so they took a rave's worth
of Molly and entered their flop era
making Speed Racer a colorful box office
duh that's become a cult classic Cloud
Atlas a colorful box office door that's
become a cult classic and Jupiter
Ascending a colorful box of a stud
that's what really this one too I create
okay might be worth a re-watch
experience a fun 80 minute movie
stretched into a two-hour Tech demo
that's like eating a bowl of eye candy
for breakfast lunch and dinner in one of
the earliest examples of stick actors in
empty rooms and doodle the film behind
them where Adobe apps take the place of
props sets and lighting while the cast
must make everything feel real on acting
skills alone oh come on take me with you
come on please
please please please please please
please please
uh oh where have you been
have any of these drivers read the rule
book oh no
holy can only Spade journey to a world
whose economy is 95 Car based and the
rest is Segways and the most popular
sport is a mix of Formula One and pro
wrestling
[Music]
as cool as it sounds like they cause a
snake but the driver's gimmick is
calling people turds
and me Speed Racer a grade A
ah luckily he's also the best driver
alive because what else could you do
with that name besides porn maybe
speed comes from a long line of expert
racists like his Pops Pops who runs an
entire high-tech racing team with a
staff of one live-in Australian house
boy I just can't believe it's not one
mention of racer Motors in here Rex
speeds uncle brother who doesn't let a
19 year old age Gap stop him from
sharing the world's worst driving advice
close your eyes Racer X a mysterious
Matthew Fox who is obviously wrecks
after faking his death but there's a
Twist he's not you're not Rex but
there's a Twist he is I wonder who's
burnt corpse he's stuck in his coffin
Trixie Christina Ricci and above so
sharp it should be called a Robert and
the comedic Duo of spiral and Chim chin
the annoying kid plus Jim Pals that will
instantly get on your nerves and stay
there
uh just remembering how much I like
Jordan peels know for no particular
reason
would you rather watch racing action
based on the most boring game since
Microsoft flights in
America or do you want racing action
based on f-zero plus Beyblades
in races that feel like watching an
earthquake at the Hot Wheels Factory
where the drivers basically try to kill
each other
Scandal is that the winners can briefly
alter a stock price oh Lookout speed
you're facilitating Royalton's corporate
buyouts only one of us are helped to
drive up the stock in his family
business yeah I feel like all the murder
is the bigger evil but he is British so
so buckle up or one of the most secretly
influential films of all time that shape
how all movies Would One Day become
green screen cartoons yeah does it look
cool or
trigger warnings for all physical
intimacy
the following image may be unsuitable
for the uninoculated or
cootie sensitive viewers and prove that
a franchise could be built on a
foundation of fast cars secretly working
for the government not making any sense
and family hey put that milk down grab a
Corona Sparky you're rolling with our
crew now
story Emil Hirsch at Sundance okay No
More Mr Nice Guy you ever race a
stranger in the Alps Susan Sarandon damn
Christina racy spider chip my ride E
Honda Insight Tokyo grift croyke racer
Twitter Lars von Tire David saslov all
that matters is power
and drive shaft Fast Times I'm really
high
I'd rather keep my mouth covered when
I'm in a convertible with my eyes these
dudes must eat like a million bugs
wanna keep things weird we asked a
spider scientist what real spider powers
would do to Peter Parker and spoiler
alert the webs come out of his butt all
that and much more will be revealed by
clicking the Box on the right to watch
now
what is this some kind of honest trailer
a fart is a song your butt sings if
bread and French is pain then I own a
bakery when I was born I cast epic voice
and rolled a natural 20. you're welcome